It was near Greece
had a dangerously
overloaded boat crowded with.
More than 750 migrants capsized in June.
Almost everyone on board drowned,
including a 14 year
old boy from Pakistan.
Women and children were locked
in the boat's cargo hold,
according to U.N.
officials,
and had little chance for survival.
CNN traveled to his home
in Punjab Province
and spoke to his devastated father.
CNN's Anna
Coren has this exclusive report.
From the lush plains of Gujarat
in Punjab Province
are home to
some of the most fertile land
in all of Pakistan.
The mighty Indus River
and its tributaries, the lifeblood.
But not everyone here
prospers from its richness.
14 year
old Muhammad
Abuza felt the heavy
burden of responsibility.
His father,
a school van driver earning
less than $90
a month, was struggling to
provide for the family
Abu abuser,
worried about the
future of his younger brothers,
especially six year old Hasan,
who is severely disabled.
We have about him in the article.
Leave it up.
My son pleaded with me to be sent abroad,
he explains.
He said,
Look at how we live will die of hunger.
It's best for me to leave.
So I can support our family
very hard here.
Many older boys from the village
had already made the trek to Europe
through human smuggling operations,
sending hefty remittances back home
and are not doing them on either
one of these abusers.
Uncle had decided to go.
And the teenager knew
this was his chance.
The people smuggler said it would cost
more than 8,000 USD
to send my son to Italy.
I said I can't afford it.
He told me,
Your kid will earn that
in a couple of months.
At the beginning of May this year, Abuza,
his uncle
and a small group of teenage boys
from the village set off human smugglers
organize for the group
to fly from Karachi to Dubai,
then to Egypt, before transiting to Libya
from Tripoli International Airport.
They drove to the Libyan port
city of Tobruk
and waited in a camp
filled with other illegal migrants
for the next month.
The day before the group
set sail for Italy,
their final destination.
Abu Zar
sent a video to his brothers,
hoping to make them laugh.
He then recorded the group's
final prayers on a car
that night.
He called his father,
Ari Gold Body.
My son was really happy.
He said, Don't worry, Dad.
It will be okay.
We'll have lifejackets.
It's a big boat.
Once on there,
you'll have nothing to worry about.
On the 9th of June, Mabuza
boarded the Adriana,
a fishing vessel with a capacity of 100
instead.
750 illegal migrants were crammed
aboard, of which almost half
were from Pakistan.
According to the Pakistani
Interior Ministry,
within days,
the trawler
would capsize off the coast of Greece
as a Greek coastguard ship watched on
more than 600 people drowned in
what would become
one of the deadliest
migrant boat tragedies.
Among the survivors, only 12 Pakistanis
abuser was not one of them.
You must see the whole country
dying of hunger is better than this.
Don't send your children away for us.
Life in hell
are now the same water today.
But this grieving father's warning
is falling on deaf ears.
According to UN migration
last year, Pakistanis weren't
even among the top ten nationalities
arriving in Europe.
This year, however,
they're ranked number five,
with economic migration
fueling the surge.
A financial crisis in Pakistan
and record high unemployment
is driving many families
to make this life altering decision.
Common narrative
that smugglers are there
to sort of
lure people
into into this dangerous journey.
We look at
who are the people that influence
the decision of migrating
and is mostly family.
So migration is a family investment.
For this mother
in Bengali
in Pakistan administered Kashmir.
Her 20 year
old son was supposed to be on
that ill fated vessel.
She says the human traffickers
disembarked him because of overcrowding.
He's now waiting for the next boat.
Like right now, just him to come home.
But he won't.
She explains
he wants to go to Europe
like other boys from our village.
I pray that he makes it
Anna Coren, CNN, Hong Kong.